we're now
at 121 attendees it's wonderful
turnout thanks to everyone for coming
i'll start again
uh my name is stephen naren i'm the
director of the fortune off video
archive for holocaust testimonies
here at yale tonight the fortune off
archive is
delighted to present the work of justice
lipovich in his ensemble
featuring sasha luria the songs you're
about to hear are taken from the second
volume of recorded works based on the
testimonies from the archive
after the concert you can learn more
about this ongoing project and listen to
both
volumes one and two and watch excerpts
from the testimonies
at our the project's accompanying
website songs from testimonies.org
before we begin i'd like to thank evan
graves from the yale institute for
sacred music and rabbi
jason rubenstein at the joseph slifka
center for jewish
life at yale for their generous support
of this concert i'd like to give you
just a few
a few bits of information about the
fortune of video archive
the archive began taping testimonies in
new haven in 1979
at the time it was called the holocaust
survivors film project or hsfp
and it was a local grassroots effort by
survivors and supporters in the new
haven area
it was the brainchild of dr dory laub
himself a survivor from chernovitz
a psychiatrist and analyst and laurel
vlog a television journalist at channel
8.
they had the support of the new haven
survivor community from the very
beginning
uh particularly in the form of a man
named william rosenberg who was a
survivor from chancellor of poland and
willie became the president of the hsfp
organized helped organize the tapings
raising funds for the tapings
and holding meetings at his home the
collection came to yale in 1981
thanks to the work of professor jeffrey
hartman jeffrey 2 was a survivor of nazi
occupied europe having fled frankfurt on
a kinder transport
for the uk and his wife renee was one of
the first four survivors
taped by the holocaust survivors film
project in 1979.
jeffrey helped fund a home for the
collection at manuscripts and archives
during memorial library and under his
watch as faculty advisor it grew to
become an internationally renowned
collection that over the years has
influenced the way the history of the
holocaust is studied
written and taught now the collection
contains something
like 4400 testimonies 12 000 hours of
recorded material
in over a dozen languages recorded over
the last 40 years
in over a dozen countries each testimony
in the collection
is really a world unto itself
functioning almost like an audio visual
autobiography
because we use an open-ended methodology
that allows for a great deal of
spontaneity and freedom
for the individual to tell their story
the way they desire because of this it's
no wonder
that song and poetry appear in so many
testimonies
historian timothy snyder the the
archives faculty advisor
has said that video testimony like works
of art have a special ability to cross
the membrane
between death and life between past and
present
the singing of these songs can't happen
in a written source the same way
they can only happen in an audio or
audio visual source
the collection preservation and
presentation of musical
performances like these also places this
project in a long line of venerable
ethnomusicological projects that stretch
back to the early 20th century
when individuals like schnansky went on
expeditions to record
the musical heritage of a jewish society
that was disappearing due to
modernization urbanization and political
turmoil
anskey called this work salvage
ethnography
this impetus to collect and record this
goal of salvaging what was left
continued through the war and into the
post-war period following the holocaust
with recordings of songs by david boder
and dp camps
and later the work of the fortune of
video archive
my point is simply we are not the first
to recognize significance of musical
expression as a mean of under means
for understanding the past and it most
certainly applies to the understanding
of the
multilingual multicultural world where
european jews lived and died
during the holocaust and with that i
would like to introduce cecil slipovic
the fortunate video archives musician
and residence
thank you stephen songstrom testimonies
in the fortunate video archive is a
project that explores and
artistically presents music and poetic
pieces performed by survivors in
testimonies
given to the archive some of the songs
were from the pre-war period
some of them gained new meaning during
the holocaust
playing many different roles but often
songs work to sustain
people psychologically in the
unimaginable conditions
when even the very act of singing a song
required enormous effort some of the
songs are not idiomatically jewish
they might be songs from the past that
acquired new topical lyrics
there are songs of struggle and
resistance
many songs that are satirical in nature
songs documenting people suffering
songs naming the traitors and
collaborationists
there are even overtly anti-semitic
songs that survivors
nevertheless chose to perform this
project
began several years ago when dr sarah
gary boba
former fortune of video archive
uh hartman fellow began research on the
testimony of libov k
a survivor of the slave labor camp is in
venigarotka ukraine
in her testimony lubov recounts several
songs and poems
later stephen and naren the archives
director
invited me to transcribe and perform the
songs
and the project has grown from there
when i started working on this
collection in 2018
i only had a sense of the richness depth
and breadth of the material i would be
examining
the more i listened to the testimonies
the more i found myself
placing them in many different contexts
european
soviet jewish musicological
ethnographical and so on when steven
asked me to record these songs it became
obvious to me
that i had to contract and ensemble
a vocalist and instrumentalist musicians
that would be the right fit
for this very challenging material among
those challenges
to name just a few are the extremely
wide range of musical styles
and many languages in which the vocalist
would have to con this
convincingly perform in the two volumes
of songs from testimonies sasha luria
sings
yiddish hebrew polish
german russian mixed yiddish german
and french the two volumes have been the
most stylistically and linguistically
diverse albums
that i have ever recorded or produced
to ensure that each song is represented
in a historically
authentic manner a great deal of
multidisciplinary research is required
even before the song is transcribed and
arranged
from the very beginning of this project
i have been very fortunate to work with
joshua camp
who plays the accordion piano in the
guitar with bassist dmitry ishenko
violinist craig gudelman and vocalist
sasha luria
mariana slapovic appears on two songs in
volume 2
on the tsimbali a belarusian string
instrument
similar to the hammered dulcimer as
time passes we obviously are moved
farther away from the origins of
of the source material but our hope is
that anyone listening to these songs
will be driven
to also learn more about the survivors
who sang them
these songs represent many things
including stories
of loss and survival stories that are
still important
to hear today when we are experiencing
a new upheaval of hateful chauvinistic
ideas
and ideologists a ideologist
anti-semitism itself sadly is hardly a
thing of the past
music in a way different from a verbal
story has the power
to educate to challenge people's
thinking
although i hope i'm not being naive i do
sincerely hope
that this will be true for these
recordings as well
we will begin our program tonight with a
song
in the naverque lily m
was born in 1924 in vilna
now vilnius lithuania then poland
in her testimony lily recalls growing up
in an assimilated affluent home
as well as the rays of anti-semitism
from 1935.
at some point lily was transported to
the external slave labor camp
tuna vaca
in the outskirts of riga latvia
according to lily's testimony her friend
tosia
had escaped with her parents from lodge
to vilna in 1939
and composed and sang this song
lily characterized torcia as a very
talented poet
those who did not survive the war really
believed
she may have died of typhus in germany
around the time of the liberation
in 1945
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
i would like to turn to the musicians
and ask them to speak about their
experiences
working with this material on both
albums joshua kemp
was the first one of this band who
encountered songs with from testimonies
thank you yeah
i was involved from the very first duo
performances
and it's been lovely to watch this
project grow and expand to what it is
today
um cecil uses the term creative
reconstruction for what we do and i
think that's a great
description of what how we
as musicians contribute to a project
like this
music performance is an ephemeral act
but through that act we can transform
something
that is perceived as being in the past
and bring it to
the here and now in our current
situation
where we as musicians cannot perform
together in front of an audience
this project has been a much needed
reminder
at least for me of the value of music
and music performance
and how it can connect us with our past
and
our shared humanity
from apple plots a memory of the roll
call
moshe b was born in 1926 in rimanuf
poland near the czechoslovakian border
after imprisonment in several camps
moshe survived the death's march
to bergen-belsen where he was liberated
by the british
troops in his testimony moshe remembers
the grim
experience of the daily roll call appel
platz in german
at one of the concentration camps the
commandant would order everyone to take
hats off
nuts uh and to sing
zingan moshe pays tribute to one of his
musically talented fellow prisoners
whose name remains unknown who sang this
song
during the roll call
my heart took me away
would you help my
[Music]
[Music]
and from 11 it hurts into harmonious
glitch
we will now hear the band perform the
[Music]
song
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
or
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is the lead vocalist of this project she
is truly a creative force
standing behind many of the ideas you
will hear in this new program
sasha i would like to ask you to share a
few words
about your work in this project
thank you cecil um
well it definitely has been
uh am i still there
just double checking yeah okay
all right so it definitely has been a
privilege
a great privilege to work with this
project for many reasons and first of
all
of course is the group of musicians
and artists and scholars that i got to
work with on this
as a singer i feel that learning this
songs from real people even
on recordings and video brings a
different level of connection to their
stories and their personal lives and
personal voices uh and by exploring the
wide range of
repertoire styles and languages
uh that the people that were interviewed
in in this testimonies were fluent in
we get a distinct picture of what it
meant to be
a jewish person before
before world war ii um
jewish people were integrated into the
society around them and were polyglot
not only in
languages but also in styles of music
literature
art and all the various cultures around
them
going between yiddish german polish
russian
or even other languages wasn't a special
unique thing
it was just part of how the world
functioned
and i get to have this unique chance to
try
out these different voices culturals and
styles
and feel them through my own voice
it definitely has been a deeply
interesting and
moving challenge to take on and
by bringing these songs to concerts
and recording them we bring new life to
the stories that people shared in their
testimonies
we bring these stories to people and
it's so important that
these stories and sounds get heard
and as zisa has already mentioned it's
sad to know that
lot of these situations a lot of
these stories are topical today
but learning this performing this
listening to this helps us remember
share our feelings and experiences
and live through the experiences
of people that were interviewed and
i hope that it will help us learn how
to be a better human
thank you sasha
the this is another song remembered by
moshe
b he sang it as a tribute to
jalazne possibly a former synagogue
cantor
a talented singer in moshe's own words
well one can one can define this piece
as a ballad
due to its great dramatic intensity it
can be also categorized as an operatic
scene
such songs would typically be performed
in cantor's concert on matse
after shabbat in this piece the
dramatist personae
include the congregation the ganseroylem
the old cantor the alter hassan the evil
gentile sailor
the poster the old rabbi
the alta roof and an old blind
jew ayida zochna blinder who ultimately
sacrifices his life
to save the community this is one of a
series of dramatic and dramatized
ashkenazic jewish ballads
that are not coincidentally set on the
eve of yom kippur
the the day of atonement this theatrical
song performed
by moshe in manner almost identical to
our recording
cuts a nearly operatic scene that
belongs to the eastern european jewish
musical tradition
while also resonating with a kind of
brechtian theater
along the lines of what we would hear
from kurt meyer
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
joseph w was born in lodge
poland in 1929
where when nazi occupation began
he he and his family were locked in the
ghetto
one of joseph's brightest memories was
the angela hashkevitz
who composed many songs in the lodge
ghetto
and was famous as the ghetto troubadour
student elster a yiddishized version
of the german student eldest
the original meaning of the term was a
senior
soldier in the barrack room
in the concentration in slave labor
camps
the word meant couple prisoner
functionary assigned by the assessed
guards to supervise
forced labor or carry out administrative
tasks
the room leader was the lowest rank
the next one was block ancestor referred
to in this song as blocovo
the block or the barracks senior
the highest position of a jew
uh in a camp would be a
capo uh lager
ancestor the camp senior
the discovery of the version of student
elsta in joseph's testimony is
particularly important as
the survivors themselves seem to want to
forget this repertoire and did not sing
this song
in the post-war period as far as we know
so let's hear a clip from
joseph's testimony
conveys the grim reality on the
unbearable conditions at the camp
the yiddish lyrics carry a strong
influence of german
as well as camp slang it would be hard
if not impossible to properly transcribe
and understand the song
if not for the good chance that we
received the assistance of samuel
norwich the publisher of the forward
norwich was born in 1947
in a dp camp in germany where such slang
was still in use
the frey looks like feeling of the song
as sung by joseph and his testimony uh
becomes a vehicle for the dark humor
that saturates the lyrics
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
i have worked with craig goodelman a
truly versatile violinist for many years
in the classroom band litvakus and i
have been always fascinated by
craig's energy and his sound
which was exactly what i was looking for
and also his willingness
to go in depth with any material that we
were
working with i would like to ask craig
to share his perspective
on working on sansa from testimonies
thanks diesel uh first of all i want to
thank thank you and all of my wonderful
colleagues in the band
as well as stephen naren and all the
people who work on the fortune of
archive itself
and especially the people who had the
presence of mind to record these
testimonies in the first place
as diesel has so clearly articulated
this collection of music draws on an
endless amount of sources and references
both jewish and non and that is
certainly one of the most striking
things for me when i think about this
collection as a whole
however surprising this diversity might
seem it's actually just what we should
expect
if you study yiddish music you quickly
learn that while there's definitely a
way to play with a yiddish accent
yiddish music like the language itself
has always been a conglomeration and a
reframing of cultures
is embedded in so often we picture
ashkenazim in isolated stentler
existing in some sort of primordial pure
state
but in real life they were always in
contact with their neighbors
and many lived in cities and in fact
much of yiddish culture was completely
imbued with cosmopolitan
and international influences part of
what makes understanding and expressing
each culture so difficult
is the amount of contextual knowledge
required to really understand it
this is challenging in any project but i
think for us as you can see it has been
one of the greatest challenges
taking a fragment of a poem or a song
sung without accompaniment during an
interview
and searching for a way to transform it
into something someone can listen to in
their own living room
and even enjoy while still honoring the
original meaning and context of the song
whether it's a song about life in the
camps a popular drinking song of its day
or even an anti-semitic song that
somehow remained in the memory of a
survivor
word for word one might think that after
the incredible betrayal these survivors
must have felt from their country
they would have refused to speak these
languages and sing the songs of their
neighbors
yet even in these darkest moments when
it must have felt clear that a person's
jewish identity would always be a
barrier to their national identity in
the eyes of their countrymen
the core of our culture was and remains
something that is in conversation with
the outside
this is of course true not only for
jewish or yiddish culture
but for all cultures and i hope that our
performance of these songs helps to
remind us all of that
well i've been studying and performing
yiddish music for a couple decades now
i mostly have stayed away from
explicitly holocaust related material
preferring to study perform and
celebrate the culture that lived
vigorously
before this travesty and is once again
today only growing stronger so often in
the america i grew up in
if we did encounter things that were
identifiably yiddish it was in the
context of the holocaust and associated
with feelings of grief
victimhood and loss i choose to engage
with this culture to reclaim my
inheritance to find life to give context
to my own experience
and to honor those who came before me
however
working on this project and trying to
understand the context of the songs and
the people who recounted them
has been hugely enriching if a bit
challenging at times
the scope of the holocaust makes it
almost impossible to comprehend
but these songs draw us into the
specific experience of individuals
and even into specific moments in their
lives i strongly encourage you all to
take some time to watch the testimonies
which are available on the archive
website
so that when you think about this
horrific chapter in our history
the first image in your mind perhaps
won't be mountains of dead bodies but
rather the faces of people strong enough
to survive it
i'm so grateful for the way this project
has been framed and i hope that as
you're watching these videos
you're able to get a sense not of how
small and confined were the experiences
of the victims of this atrocity
but of how big was the world that they
carried inside themselves
and how interconnected it was and
remains despite the continuing efforts
to claim culture and land as the sole
property of just a few
wow thank you
yeah well domain
well i guess we'll move on
the next song or himlin or himland
is a powerful
chilling song recounted by moshe f
born in un yehuv
poland in 1913.
when moshe arrived in auschwitz he met a
man by the name of
meyer bear gutman
or goodman who
could write he wrote two poems
azoy we been the hoischritzke men when i
came to auschwitz
and himland or himland these minecraft
heavens or heavens where is my luck
both were set to the melodies of popular
songs
of the period the first one
was originally a rejoicing song that
recounts
all the jewish holidays and celebrates
how
it is good to be a jew ah
and the juxtaposition of this new text
and the old melody creates a sense of
tragic irony that likely would
would have been clear to the listeners
of the time
the second tune and verse which gives
the title to this composition
uses the melody of a popular song
in russian
polish where is that street where is
that house it was a
very very popular song
m
[Music]
bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hearts
[Music]
um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
is
[Music]
there
[Music]
and
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
i've had an honor of working with the
bassist dmitry ishenko
on a wide range of projects from klezmer
band
he's a substitute bass player in
litvakis band
to improvised music dmitry plays in
zesel slokovic trio along with the
wonderful guitarist nadavlev
to musical theater fiddler on the roof
and yiddish
being one of the more recent productions
and more
it is truly my pleasure to ask dmitry to
share his story of working on
songs from testimonies thank you so much
zizel
uh well it has been a real true honor
for me to be part of this project
and it really has exposed me to a whole
wide variety of music
in a multitude of languages that comes
out of the holocaust area
and not all of it being sad some of it
being quite hopeful and optimistic
and from a personal perspective
uh for me it's a dedication to the
jewish side of my family
that hails from uh odessa ukraine
and uh the surrounding areas
uh and their struggles during that era
and to the several relatives that i know
of who have perished during that time
at the hands of the nazi allies thank
you
thank you me tim this next song
haitam nagurtza hey there on the hill
was drawn from the testimony of yaakov
bee
yakov was born in rubiashuf poland in
1926
the youngest of three children he first
attended the jewish school
but then underwent a compulsory transfer
to the public polish school
from those years he remembers walking
around the town with the girls
and learning funny and frivolous songs
from them
hey tom nagurza is a traditional polish
song
with a pronounced 3-4 dance field
this inspires us to pair inspired us to
pair the song with an
oberek dance tune from the micro region
residuza a town near jakob's hometown of
rubi ashraf
the song belongs to the group of
light-hearted polish songs about a
soldier
flirting with a young girl we suspect
that
jakob b might have added his own name to
the
song lyrics it's impossible to know
if the original version of the song use
the
jewish name yaakov or yankel
or the polish name jakob
hey
a
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from
[Music]
medium
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
[Music]
my
this next piece juaper crostropic is
composed of two songs
from two different testimonies one is
the satirical
polish song juappa crosstrope is a
village hustler
overheard in the streets of warsaw by
salman h
then a little boy born in 1929
the song's general concept is poking fun
and
at uneducated yet street smart peasants
zalman did not remember one of the lines
that were able to discover in a source
that contained the full text
as the character is ironically making
fun of his girlfriend
pointing out that she dresses too fancy
she fires back
noting that her wojtek bought a fur coat
from the jew in the ghetto
it was obviously a cheap code and he
didn't see anything particularly immoral
about this purchase in my arrangement i
have cut this song's lyric
at that dramatic turn and transitioned
to the next picture from exhibition so
to speak from a testimony given by
coleman
a
um coleman was born in 1928
i a native of calmness lithuania
he resemble he remembers one verse of a
song portraying
a strict polish collaborationist
who is guarding the entrance of the
ghetto
he suddenly becomes happy when he sees
an opportunity to get a cut of what is
likely
food being illegally smuggled into the
ghetto
the characters of both songs represent
the same figure a non-jew
former neighbor who under new
circumstances
doesn't mind benefiting personally
from the misery of jews the moral
opposite of those who risk their lives
by hiding their jewish neighbors from
the nazis
[Music]
yes
me
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the last song in our tonight's concert
is should i
cry my heart cry the title track on the
second
volume of songs from testimonies
in interwar europe including the
soviet union latin american music was
immensely popular
it is no surprise that some songs of
survival and resistance during
and after the war adapted popular
latin american tunes to new lyrics and
became
widespread as new pieces
the musical origins of the so-called
treblinka song lie in tango
oracion composed by the prominent
argentinian composer
and tango orchestra director eduardo
bianco
while the treblinka song is based on
oracion
it has its own distinct
feel tempo and form
we find this song in more than one
testimony
both in the fortune of two two
testimonies in the fortune of video
archive and in the united states
holocaust memorial museum collection
it was sung by maurice k which we that
version we use
as the main reference for this recording
willie f
who presents a short fragment from the
song
and frida burstin radaski who sang a
fuller but also a slightly different
version titled
treblinka dalt there lies treblinka
the song conveys the story of frequent
deportations from
warsaw's unschlage plots to treblinka
as seen and felt by the ghetto prisoners
maurice k
born in 1917 heard the song while he was
still living with his family
in his hometown pawanyas situated more
than 230 kilometers or
140 miles south of warsaw
before they were ordered to leave in
october 1942
another survivor willie f born in
javascite
in 1928 uh lived through
um the croc of ghetto tuashov
skarzyusko kamenda and buchenwald
concentration camps
he learned the song in krakow flash of
area which is
even farther away from warsaw
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
she
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much everyone for joining
us tonight
i would like to remind you that you can
access songs from testimonies volume 2
as well as volume 1 at
songsfromtestimonies.org
which will lead you to the dedicated web
page at fortune of video archive
you can download the album uh also along
with the volume
one at zizel zisl.bandcam.com
steven is now copying those links uh
into the chat
so you can uh click through the vinyl
lps
and the cds are still in production for
the volume 2 and will become
available shortly however volume 1
lps and cds are available in limited
quantities
tonight's artists were sasha luria
and the zesel sapovic ensemble joshua
kemp
on the accordion and keyboard
dmitry ischenko on the counter base
craig udelman on the violin and guest
artist
mariana slipovich on that symbol
i am cecil slipovich i played the
woodwinds arranged the songs
translated the lyrics wrote liner notes
and conceived this program
stephen aaron is the director of the
fortune of video archive
for holocaust testimonies at yale
university dr
gillaflam wrote an introductory note for
this album
which is also available on songs from
testimonies.org website
video editing is by magdalena hooter
sound editing by joshua kemp english
subtitles are done by sasha luria
the vinyl lp mastering as well as vinyl
and cd manufacturing and booklet layout
are all masterfully done thanks to the
expertise of jeff miller
of dexterity press the album art and
animation in there is an
upcoming animation which you probably
saw on the
social media advertisements that is done
by yulia ruditsky
a wonderful artist and animation artist
living in brooklyn but also my
expat from belarus um
thank you very much again and stay well
and see you
next time hopefully live